a very warm welcome to all our viewers
i'm anjali from simply learn
and today you'll be learning what lists
in python
are so we'll start with the basic
definition
of what a list is we'll then see how you
can create the list
we then have accessing of the elements
in the list
the various operations that can be done
on the list and then methods and build
in functions
specifically for lists and finally we'll
have a short exercise using some of the
concepts that we learned today
so what are lists a list is a collection
of
data and this data could be of any data
type
in fact a list could hold data of
different data types
as we can see in our example down here
we have a list named
x and x holds 1 89
the single letter a the string hey
another number 0 and the capital letter
b now another important factor with
lists are it indices every element in
the list
has a position and this position is
called an index
the first position in a list is always 0
so 1 is at index 0 89 at
index 1 a at index 2 and so on
so this means that the position of your
last
element would be the length of your list
minus 1.
so now that you know what a list is
let's move on to how you can create a
list
so this is my jupiter notebook and we'll
start by creating the most basic
list which is an integer list so my list
name would be
num and then open square brackets and
within this
just put in your numbers separated by
commas
so that is my first list run this
and there seems to be no error let's now
print this list out just to see
what it looks like
and as you can see the elements that we
inserted in this list are printed
which are 1 2 3 and 4.
next let's create a list with just
single characters
so my list name is letter and the syntax
is exactly the same
you open square brackets and now that we
have
letters inside which are characters
you type these within quotes
let's print this too
and once again after the run you can see
the letters that we inserted into our
list letter
next let's create a list of strings
so i'll name my list stg
open square braces and again strings
should always be written within double
or single quotes
and that's my list of strings
i'll print this too great so now we have
created a list of only integers
only letters and only strings now as
i mentioned before list can contain a
combination of different data
types so let's try that out
i'll name my list mix because it's going
to be a mix of number strings
two numbers and then i'll follow this up
with
a few strings
and let's run it so that works perfectly
fine
now lists have another format if you
have worked with any other programming
language previously
you would have come across the term
matrix so usually in
other programming languages matrix are
associated with
arrays so they are basically 2d arrays
in case of pythons
matrix can also be of lists so you can
have a list
containing two or more lists so let's do
that
i'll name my list matt as in short for
matrix
open square braces and since the
elements of this list are
also list put these two in square braces
so our first list would be 1 comma 2
and then comma because our second list
is basically the second
element of our list mat and our second
list would be
a b and that's how you create
a list containing list so our parent
list
is mat and this contains two lists
the first list is one comma two and the
second list is a comma b
so let's print this out
and there you go so we also created a
list containing list
so these are the different type of lists
you can create
next we'll move on to how you can access
the elements within this list
so there's no point of creating a list
if you cannot access each individual
element within the list
now here to understand how to access the
elements of the list
we'll be using the list mix that we
created previously
so before we start i'll just print out
mix
so you can have an idea of what is
inside
so we have five elements within mix the
first two
are numbers or integers 1 comma 6 and
that's followed up by 3 strings
simply learn get certified we previously
saw that
every element in the list has an index
position
so the simplest way of accessing an
individual element in the list
is by following the list name with
square braces
and within the square braces mention the
index number
of the particular element so if i want
to access the element get
my index would be 0 1
2 3 so mix of 3
and i'll run this we got our element get
now in a similar way you can also use
negative indices
to access the elements so when you put a
negative sign
the indices are basically counted from
the back of the list
now if i want to access the same word
get but all i know about this word
position is that it's a second last word
in the list
i also do not know the length of the
list in this case
i can just say mix of minus two
so two as in it's the second last
element
and the minus signifies that you count
from the end of the list and not from
the beginning
so i'll run this and extracted get
now as you probably would have noticed
in case
of indices when counted from the front
of the list it starts with zero
on the other hand when you count the
indices from the end of the list
it starts with -1 and not 0. so now we
saw how you can access a single element
from the front of the list and from the
back of the list
now what if you want to access a range
of elements
say i want to extract the first three
elements of the list
mix in that case i could just type mix
again square braces and within here i'll
put colons
followed by three so ideally there would
be a number
on either side of the colon but in this
case we are taking from the beginning of
the list
so if the digit before the colon is
supposed to be zero
you can just leave it blank and
automatically it's interpreted as zero
also we know that our third element
would be at the index position two
but here we have written index position
three
this is because our last index positions
always
excluded so if you give two instead of
three then the only elements that would
be extracted would be the ones
at zeroth and first position since we
want the element at the second position
to
we give the ending index as 3 so let's
print this
and we received our first three elements
of the list mix which are 1
6 and the word simply learn now what if
we want to extract
all the elements from a certain position
of the list
say our third index position of the list
up till the end of the list in that case
again we have mix square braces and we
have the same
colons as we used previously but now
since we want our starting index to be 3
we enter 3 and the element at the third
index would be included
but now we want to extract all elements
till the
end of the list so you can just leave
the last position blank
when you do this it's automatically
interpreted
that you're taking all the elements up
till the end of the list
let's run this and we received get and
certified
now i want to extract the word simply
learn
and get from our list mix
in this case what would be the
parameters within our square braces
so simply learn is at the index location
2 and get is at the index location 3
so our starting index would be 2 but as
we already mentioned
previously if i put 3 as my ending index
i would not receive the element
at the index position three therefore
i'll put my ending index as
four and run this and there you go we
received our two word simply learn and
get
now here's something slightly more fun
so what if i want to extract
every second element of my list in that
case i put two double colons
followed by two because i want every
second element of my list
and run this so as you see here one
has been printed which is followed by 6
in our list mix but 6 is skipped and
then we have simply learn
again the word get is kip and we have
certified
now there's one more thing you can do
with list indices
you can print them in the reverse order
so to do that just two colons
and minus one let's print that
and as you can see your list mix is
printed in the reverse order
so now if we go back to line 16
these two double colons are basically
positions for your indices
so suppose you want the second element
from the first
index and not the zeroth index you can
write
one here and if you want every second
element from the first index up to say
the fifth index
you can put 5 here but in our case we
did not have a fifth index
so i'll just leave it at this you can
obviously try that out
in fact we'll be using a variation of
this in our exercise later on
so now that we saw how you can access
the various elements of the list
let's look at the various operations you
can perform on the list
suppose you want to create a list of a
hundred zeroes
if we go by the traditional methods we'd
literally have to type in a hundred
zeros separated by commas within the
square braces
and this gets very tedious so a short
way of doing this
is type in that one element
that you want repeated multiple times
within your list
and outside the square braces follow it
up
with asterisks digit and the number of
times you want this element to be
repeated
so 0 into 100
and let me print this
[Music]
and as you see a hundred zeros exist
within our list
c now we can also create a new list
concatenating two or more or less so
let's create a list concatenating the
two lists that we previously created
letter and sdj so i'll just print these
lists
out first
[Music]
that's our list letter
[Music]
and that's our list sdg now we'll create
a new list
call con a short form for concat
and how do you concatenate two lists
well you just
add an addition sign between them so
letter
plus stg and that's all it takes
to join two lists let's print out kong
and there you go so the first four
elements in our list
con is from the list letter and the last
four elements
is from the list sdg now there's another
operation with list
called unpacking so here you basically
give a string
as an argument to this function list and
that
unpacks each element of the string as
a separate element in the list so i'll
show you this with an example
if i name a list where and
list off within the brackets
i enter the string i say hey there
and now i'll print var
so as you can see every letter of this
string hey there
has become a single element in the list
var now let's check out another
operation
on list using the list num that we
created previously
so once again i'll just print num out so
we can recall what
was within it we had the four numbers
one two three four
now suppose i want the first element
of my list num which is 1 to be
in a variable 1 and i want the rest of
the elements
to be stored in another list called say
others
how do i do this i can just put one
which is my first variable a comma
and then star other equal to num
so what happens here is that the star
signifies
that every element that has not been put
into the previous variable or variables
is
put into this list other
so let's print out the variable 1
and the list other separately and see
what they contain
and as expected 1 contains the value 1
which is the first element of our list
num
and the following elements of our list
which are 2 3 and 4
are stored in the list other let's now
look at a few methods
specific to list so for the following
few examples we'll be using
the list that we created previously
called num
i'll print the list out first so num has
the elements 1 2 3
and 4. now the first method that we'll
be using is the append method
and the syntax for that is the list name
which is num
dot append followed by brackets
and within these brackets you basically
insert the element
that you want to add to the end of your
list
so suppose i want my list to be one two
three four
six all i do is enter six here
and that should ideally add six to the
end of your list now
so now let's print out num
and there you go so previously our list
contained the numbers one two three four
and after we executed the num dot append
method
six was added to the end now what if we
do not want to add a single element to
the end of the list but an entire other
list
so in this case we can use the method
extend
the syntax for this is num dot extend
and within the brackets you'll enter the
name of the list you want to add
to your previous list so here i want to
add the list stg
that we created previously to the end of
my list num
now before i execute this command
let me just print out sdg so we know
what's in there
so within sdg i have get certified get
ahead
i'll just delete this cell
and now i'll run the command so let's
print out
num and as you see
num previously had one two three four
six from here
and then we added get certified get
ahead
to the end of this list now now these
kind of additions
only take place at the end of the list
what if we want to insert an
element somewhere in between the list
for this
we use the method insert
and the syntax is your list name num dot
insert and within brackets you
first enter the position or the index at
which you want to
enter the new element so i want to
insert the string
simply learn just before get so this
is my fifth position so my first
parameter here would be
5 followed by the element i want to
enter
which is a string simply learn so i'll
type it within quotes
and let me run that let's now see what
num looks like
and as you see here we have one two
three four six
and then we have the new element that we
just inserted simply learn
followed by the elements which were
previously in our sdg
list alone now there's another method
you might come across
regularly which is the remove method so
this method
as the name suggests removes a element
it basically removes the first
occurrence of that particular element so
the syntax for this is num dot
remove and within the brackets you enter
the element that you want to remove
so i'll remove the element simply learn
and run
let's now see what num holds
so as you can see simply learn has been
removed
now if there were two occurrences of
simply learn
one here and maybe one after a head
only this word would be removed and not
the one
later on because it removes only the
first occurrence of that particular word
or that particular element okay
so now let's create a new list say bad
one
and we'll just insert a few letters in
here
now imagine you receive a list like this
where there are few elements but in a
jumbled order
you want to sort out this list one
simple method
sort is all you need to do that dot sort
off
run it and now let's print out
what var1 holds so all your elements
in var1 are now sorted python also
provides
a few built-in functions that can be
used with lists
so we'll have a look at the most basic
ones
so before we begin let's create a list x
and i'll fill my list with just integers
so that's my list and we'll use this
list throughout all of built-in
functions
now the most basic built-in function and
the most commonly used
is len what len does is it tells you
the length of your list so len of
x and the length is
our next built-in function that we'll
try out is min
min gives you basically the minimum of
all the elements that's present in your
list
so min of x and the minimum element in
our list
is 4. similarly we also have max which
gives you the maximum of the elements
present in the list
max of x which is 90. now we also have a
function
sum which basically gives you the sum of
all the elements present in your list so
sum of
x and that's 189 now
in python we do not have a function
which gives you the average but it's
very simple to calculate this
we do so using the sum function so you
find the sum
and then you divide that by the length
of the list
so sum of x by len of x
would give you the average of x so for
our exercise we need to create a list
of numbers from one to ten we'll call
this list
one and then we'll split list one into
two lists
odd which contains all the odd elements
of the list one
and even which contains all the even
elements of list one
so now let's move on to our jupiter
notebook and see how this is done
so let's first create our list one which
will contain all the elements from one
to ten now you can use the traditional
methods
and enter all your numbers from 1 to 10
within these square braces separated by
commas
or we look at a simpler way of doing
this
just say list and to this you pass the
function
range and within range you specify the
range
of the element you want within list one
so i want all
the elements from 1 up to 10 so my
ending index would be 11 and they are
separated by commas
let's run this and
let's print list one
and there you go so all your digits from
one to ten is stored within list one
now the next thing we need to do is as i
mentioned earlier we need to split list
1 into
odd and even and odd list will contain
all the odd elements and even will
contain all the even elements
so let's start with odd
so my list name is odd and the elements
will be taken from list
one and now the tricky part how do we
specify the
indices in this case so if you remember
previously
we had gone through an example where we
want to access every second element
in which case our index was mentioned
like this where the two
indicated that every second element
would be taken from the list
so in this case two since odd numbers
occur after
every second element our interval is
still two
and we'll start from the zeroth position
of the list which is one
and go up till the end so this is our
command
let's see what odd holds
and as you can see odd has all the odd
numbers from list one
now we need to store all the even
numbers from list1
into this list even
again our interval would be 2 but this
time
if we just skip every second element
from the beginning
even would have all the odd numbers
so what we do is we start skipping the
second element
from our second element so from index 1
onwards
we'll start skipping every second
element
print out even and there you go
so our list even has the even numbers 2
4 6 8
and 10. so with that we successfully
completed our exercise
and we also come to an end to list in
python
if you have any doubts please post them
in the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you
please hit the like button if you like
the video also subscribe to our channel
as we have a lot more coming up this is
anjali signing off
see you all next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here